- Welcome back for the second session.
We are delighted to
continue the conversation,
hopefully, inside the room, not outside.
So we are set up for a great 200 session.
So I'm going to start by
introducing our first speaker
and then after that we'll
jump directly to my colleague,
Nick, who will introduce Esther,
and then we'll take questions
from both of them at the end of it.
So Lucas Chancel
is an Associate Professor
at Science PO Paris.
He's actually visiting Harvard
Kennedy School this year,
so we were lucky to be
able to get him to come.
His research focuses on global inequality
and environmental policy,
and he's the co-director
and senior economist
at the World Inequality Lab
at the Paris School of Economics.
So, Lucas.
- Good morning, everybody.
I'm delighted to be here
and would like to thank the organizers
of this great conference.
My talk is entitled,
"Addressing Inequality
Under Climate Change:
Issues in Measurement and Policy."
And I would like to start
with some of the introductory remarks
and comments made by Rohini earlier today.
I think the introductory
remarks stressed one
of the key achievements
of the past three decades,
which is this reduction of global poverty
by historic quantities,
by historic numbers, sorry.
At the same time,
and is this?
At,
sorry.
At the same time,
despite this strong
reduction in global poverty,
which is one of these very positive traits
of globalization of over
the past three decades,
economic inequality
remains very large globally
and the world is still
very far from being flat
as it had been assumed that
it would be in some discourses
three or four decades ago.
There are still huge numbers
of people in extreme poverty
who might also live side by side
with people with very high
levels of wealth and affluence.
And so what we've also observed
over the past three decades
is this rise of inequality
within major economies
in the Global North and
in the Global South.
Climate change tends
to exacerbate economic inequality
trends between countries,
and I'll be saying a few words about that.
It also affects inequality
trends within countries
and it makes more challenging the growth
of a global middle class.
And so the question that I'm going to ask
in the coming 15 minutes
is how to address inequality
on the warming planet.
And so to kickstart this discussion,
I'm drawing from a few numbers
from the World Inequality Report
with my colleagues Thomas
Piketty, Emmanuel Saez,
and Gabriel Zucman were,
we show here the level of
income inequality on your left
and the level of wealth
inequality in the world
on the right hand side of the graph.
So at the global level,
the top 10% of income earners
make about 50% of all incomes
and the bottom 50%
of the world distribution
make a little less than 10%
of all incomes.
When it comes to wealth and equality,
either picture is more extreme, so to say.
The top 10% of wealth owners own close
to three quarters of everything
there is to own on this planet.
And the bottom half of the
world distribution owns
just 2% of global wealth.
So that's the key basic
starting point of the discussion
that I will try to pursue today.
Another important fact I
think is that inequality
has been rising in many large countries
or economies over the past
three or four decades.
And here you see the top
10% national income share
across a few regions or
countries North America,
in blue Europe,
in green Russia, Central Asia,
in purple China and India in red
and yellow on this graph.
One of the key insights
from this literature
and economic inequality is
that inequality has been rising
but it has been rising
at different speeds.
And so this means that there
are actually different ways
to open up to international trade.
There are different ways to
embrace new technologies,
there are different ways to
navigate this changing world
and to reduce poverty as well.
And I think this is going
to be one of the argument
that I will try to make when it comes
to tackling climate change
and to dealing with the
inequality issues associated
with climate change.
There are different ways
in which we can actually
do the energy transition.
And the question here is,
how is climate change intersecting
with economic inequality
or perhaps more generally
with inequalities
in human development?
And so the discussion on climate change
and inequality has been,
and this was also stress
in the introduction
for a long time, focused on
inequity between generations,
between now and the future.
For some time now,
scholars have been starting
to focus more on the now problem,
inequalities within a generation.
And here I'd like to borrow
some word first point
from Boyce in his book 2002,
stressing that pollution
is ultimately about winners
and losers.
Without losers, whether humans
or non humans,
alive or yet to be born without losers,
there's no pollution,
but there's no pollution
either without winners,
otherwise either it's a trivial problem
or it's not going to be sustained
for a long time.
So it is a distributional matter.
It is a distributional issue
with winners and losers.
Now, when trying to measure it
or to analyze pollution from
an inequality perspective,
there might be different
ways to think about it.
There are different
dimensions, global scale,
national scale, sub-national
scale, micro level,
different metrics, monetary,
physical, sociodemographic,
and different types of effects
that we might be looking at
or dimensions here.
And equally in terms of
impacts, who is impacted
by climate change, by environmental change
or different ways to
contribute to the problem.
Who is polluting in what quantities
through which pollutants,
but also inequality in capacity
to face environmental changes
or inequalities in
capacity to face policies
hat address interpretable changes.
And I think the echo has come back, right?
Very much actually, it is growing
- [An Audience] What
you're saying is so good.
- Right. So shall we make a
pause or shall I continue?
Okay.
So let me just finish this slide
by saying that this is a burgeoning field
in the social sciences,
in which interdisciplinary
research is paramount.
and that's a good news that
I think is an exciting news
for a diverse audience of scholars,
of researchers like the one here today.
One of the key issues
is that these analyses,
these metrics on
environmental inequalities,
on carbon inequalities,
pollution inequalities,
are often missing from
official statistics.
They're still not quite
present in the dashboards
used by governments to think
about environmental policy
or to think about Economic
and Social policy.
and now I think that the
echo has actually ended.
So thank you, thank
you very much for that.
And so what I will try to focus
on in the next few minutes,
we'll draw from a few recent papers
that are written down here, plus
some broader work from the
Climate Equality Literature
that will also refer to,
and the starting point
is what we call here with
my colleague Phillip Bothe,
and Tancrede Voituriez,
the Triple Climate Inequality Crisis.
So here we try to
represent three dimensions
of global climate inequality,
not necessarily exhaustive,
but we think they map a
fairly good amount of types
of inequalities we might
want to think about.
In red you have the inequality
in relative losses associated
with climate change.
By relative losses here,
I mean that we look at
income losses of individuals,
but we're controlling for
average income differences
between countries.
Okay? So these are relative income losses
after having controlled for
differences in average income
between countries.
And so here we see that the bottom 50%
of emitters at the global level
in fact make up three quarters
of all relative income losses associated
with climate change.
The second dimension in
green is the inequality
in emissions in pollution.
Some have called this type
of inequality and emission
and inequality in gains, there are losers
and there are winners.
And so pollution can also be seen
or contributions to CO2 emissions
can also be seen as mapping
fairly well the gains associated
with climate change and
with this pollution.
And so here the other inequality
that is represented here is this one
by which the top 10% of
global emitters represent more
or less a little less
than 50% of all emissions.
And then the third category
here is the inequality
and capacity to finance the transition
or the inequality to face
in ability to face climate policies
to be resilient in the face of it.
And here this,
this is basically relatively
badly proxied so to say,
and I think there's much more
work to be done on the matter
y basically the Inequality
and Wealth ownership
at the global level.
So basically restating what I was showing
before, the top 10% of wealth owners make
around three quarters of global wealth.
So that is the, that is
the general framework
of this intervention.
Today I will be looking
at these three types
of climate inequalities
and for each type I will review
ome key findings from recent research
and discuss some issues associated
with the current state of thinking.
So an unequal losses GDP
impacts associated
with temperature increases have been found
to be quite unequally
spread across the world
with climate change tending
to exacerbate inequality
between countries.
And so tropical and
subtropical nations appear
to be more impacted by climate
change, by the climate change
that has already been happening.
And this is largely through the channel
of agricultural productivity impacts,
which we've discussed earlier today.
Now it is also quite,
and so we may wanna discuss
how, sorry, how these,
these estimates are produced.
What are the underlying models used
to produce such estimates?
owever,
this inequality of impacts
I think is is something
that is quite well established.
As well as the fact
that within countries,
not just between countries
but within countries, poorest
groups tend to be more exposed
to environmental changes,
to environmental damage.
And when environmental
damage hits populations,
poorest groups are also
more vulnerable to it.
And so this leads to
climate change leading
o higher inequalities
within countries as well.
And here Hallegatte
and Rosenberg for instance,
have this interesting result
looking at household surveys
for dozens of countries
and simulating shocks associated
with environmental damages,
they find that the bottom
50 40% of the distribution
loses 70% more than the average
due to environmental shock.
So the bottom 40%, the poorest groups
of the population more
impacted by the average.
y the way,
that kind of study here looks
at developing countries.
But the literature has also found
that this is not just a
developing country characteristic.
We also see strong climate inequalities
and impacts in rich countries as well.
So it has been shown for instance
that heat waves are going
to hit socioeconomically
most deprived group
more than the average for instance,
and here I'm just referring to this work
y Obradovich and Co-authors
were they look at differences
between low income,
high income women, men,
individuals when it comes to
the effect of heat exposure
on the probability of
reporting mental health issues.
And so this is also maybe an area
where more work can be
done to make such results
even more granular and more precise.
But there's a strong
case here of intersection
between gender class and
climate inequalities.
Now some issues in this
inequality of losses stream
f the literature I think
is that standard approaches
to measuring climate
risk or climate impact
can lead to mist targeting.
So here what this global map
shows is the economic value
at risk of flooding
across the world measured
in US dollar purchasing power parity.
And so you see some form of distribution
of these losses across the globe.
Now when the question you're
gonna ask might be a question
of what's the number of people
in poverty that are affected,
he map might look pretty
radically different here.
So here this is the population
share which is below a dollar
1.9 poverty threshold and
which is also at flood risk.
So we have a very different representation
of what this inequality is about.
So I think that what I've
been trying to discuss
here is that there's this
need for very granular data.
We've been looking at that earlier today
and I think there is a strong
evolution in recent work here.
Also mobilizing large
scale satellite imagery
o look at these issues.
But there's also a need
for the use of combination
of monetary and non-monetary metrics
to understand these inequalities.
And so this is again this strong call
for even more interdisciplinary
research on the matter.
The challenges ahead, I
think, again connecting
with some of the discussion earlier today
is how to produce real-time estimates,
how to produce forecasts
that can be used by policy
o target their social policy
measures, for instance,
to anticipate climate
shocks and their impacts
and also how to think about
and how to measure the joint
distribution of consumption
of income and capital
and how these are impacted
by climate change.
And this is something which
I think still quite a bit
of work can be done.
It's already quite difficult
to measure the consumption
of income capital and consumption jointly.
nd it's even more complex to simulate
or to estimate
how climate change might
affect these distributions.
Now let me look at the
inequality of contributions.
So the inequality of contributions.
So that was my green bars here.
The first way to look at
the problem is really the,
this historical inequality
of contributions here.
So over 1850 to 2020 North America
and Europe represented
about half of all emissions.
and so the key question is how
to split the remaining budget
across countries and across individuals.
But this first big dimension
of inequality of contributions.
Another way to look at this is to look
at the inequality in average
contributions across the world.
So global average GHG emissions per capita
around six tons per person in 2019
with Sub-Saharan Africa around
1.6 tons per person per year
on average in North America,
a little more than 20 tons per
person per year on average.
Now, sorry, one of the big question
is then how are we gonna
split these averages
across the distribution.
So not looking just as at averages,
but looking at the inequality
between individuals,
there are many different ways to do it.
The bottom line I'd like
to to say is in this graph
these are results for
bottom 50%, middle 40%,
top 10, top 1%.
so these are the share in total emissions,
the results from different studies.
The bottom line
is that these various studies
mobilizing different types
of methodologies seem to come
up with relatively similar numbers.
And what are these numbers?
The top 10% of the
distribution of income earners
or consumers or emitters represent more
or less 45% of all emissions
and the bottom half of
the world population emits
between seven, 7% and 15% of the total.
So that's a relatively standard
result in this literature.
Another result,
this one from one specific study
and with all due respect
for our Prime Minister Indira Gandhi
that was referred to earlier,
in fact what we see here is that poverty
in itself is not the big chunk
of the problem at the global level
when it comes to CO2 emissions here.
Bottom 50% of the world
population, less than 10%
of emissions, but even the eradication
of extreme poverty itself
would not represent according
to Bruckner and Co-author,
such a big increase in overall emissions.
So this is top 1% emissions
compared with emissions required
to eradicate $1.9
or 3.2 a dollar poverty.
So the big question is the
growth of the middle class.
It is not the eradication
of extreme poverty.
Now another result from this literature
I think is there has been
somewhat of a big shift
in the relative importance of
between versus within
country carbon inequality
over the past four decades.
So this is a Theil decomposition
of the global inequality in
individual carbon emissions.
And so according to these
results in the early 1990s,
a little more than 60%
of global inequality
is due to between country differences.
So to average differences between China
and US Europe for instance,
this inequality has
been reducing over time.
And now we are in a world
where most of the inequality,
most of global carbon equality
is due to within country differences.
This doesn't mean that
there aren't big differences
in average emission levels between regions
and I refer to one of the
earlier graphs I've presented.
But it means that on top of
this we're now in a world
where there's also quite a big amount
of inequalities within countries.
Let me in the interest
of time, so two minutes,
three minutes, alright,
in the interest time,
just maybe flagging some key issues
in this literature on the
attribution of emissions
to individuals, it is
quite straightforward
to attribute direct
emissions to individuals
or to households.
So think about the carbon
that you emit when you use
your car that uses gasoline
or think about the emissions
from your gas heater for instance.
That's really easy to
attribute to individuals.
When it comes to attributing all emissions
within that are associated
with production processes to individuals.
It's more complicated.
One of the IPCC gives
basically two criterions
to do so one is that of exclusivity.
You don't wanna count the
same ton of carbon twice
for two different actors,
but also of you need to be comprehensive.
So you wanna count direct
and also in direct emissions.
And to do this in a systematic
framework at the level
of a country as a whole
and even more at the level of the world
is quite challenging.
And so the standard approach
to that has been to
distribute all emissions
to consumers using input output tables.
So trade tables connected
with pollution data
and to allocate all these
emissions to consumers.
And I think that's a good way to proceed.
At the same time, this
tends to miss the role
of savings, the role of
investors in driving emissions
or in driving decarbonization.
This tends to omit the
fact that as consumers
we sometimes have limited information,
limited agency.
And so this approach
to measuring emissions
solely focused on consumer
is actually in some ways limited.
And just to give you an
insight of what I'm trying
to say here, this is the distribution
of carbon footprint in the US in 2019.
That's a consumer perspective.
Full population,
a little more than 20
tons per person per year.
The top 10% of the
population here is a little
above 50 tons per person per year.
Now if I'm doing the same thing,
so attributing US emissions
to US individuals,
if I'm attributing direct emissions,
again to those who are responsible
for these direct emissions.
But if I am attributing emissions
from production processes
in a different way, not
to the final consumers
of goods,
but to the owners of the
industries that pollute,
this is the kind of picture
that I would have the top 10%
in that case emits a hundred tons
of CO2 per person per year.
So a factor two different.
So this is,
and I'll skip all this in the
interest of time just to say
that the consumption
approach has been very useful
to think about emissions
responsibility and inequality,
but it might be quite limited
and better measuring emissions associated
with wealth is key.
This might lead us to
having other new insights
of how to think about the
incidents of carbon taxes
and of regulations.
And I will skip the final part
which was really about
this third dimension here.
The capacity to finance.
Maybe just by saying that we
might think from this graph
that this is essentially a Global North
versus a Global South
issue, capital in the North
and relative losses are in the South.
However, there are also very
large wealth inequalities
in each region of the world.
So even in Europe,
which is a relatively
equal region in this world,
the bottom 50% of the population owns
less than 5% of wealth.
So this has implications
in how we're gonna think
about bridging the global
climate finance gap,
who should bridge this gap?
Private actors, public actors,
how to think about that
in a context of strong,
relatively strong inequalities.
And how to think about that in a context
where the investments we
make today are not only going
to determine the ecological state
of the world in the
future, but also contribute
to shape economic inequalities
in the decades to come.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(audience clapping)
- So wonderful.
Thank you for this introduction
and then sort of tour of the
facts on climate inequality
in particular this focus
on bridging the gap.
So we're now gonna turn the
attention in the conference
towards exactly that.
What can governments and markets
do to address some of the problems
that we've seen in these
first two sessions?
And to kick that off,
I'm very pleased to introduce
Professor Esther Duflo.
Professor Duflo is the
Abdul Latif Jameel Professor
of Development Economics
and Poverty Alleviation
in the Department of Economics at MIT.
She's the co-founder and co-director
of the Abdul Latif Jameel
Poverty Action Lab,
which really sort of led the innovation
of using randomized experiments
as we saw in the first session
in development economics.
And her own research has
spanned an incredible range
of topics within development
from credit and finance
to education and health,
governance, inequality,
and environment as well,
as well as contributions
to empirical methods.
So this is really a remarkable set of work
and it's been recognized broadly including
with the inaugural 2008 BBVA
Frontiers of Knowledge Award
and the 2019 Nobel Prize in economics.
So it's a great pleasure.
Please welcome Professor Duflo.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you. Thank you so much.
And by way of preliminary,
like an interloper,
I have done some work
on environment with Nick
with among others, but
it's been some time,
and what I'm going to
talk about today involves
almost no randomized control trial,
although it has some plug for them.
So I kind of one of these older people
who use their previous work to
justify shouting their mouth
about everything.
So I apologize for that,
but a lot of what I'm going
to say are things that you guys know,
but maybe that's also giving kind of a way
of packaging it for the rest of the world,
which might also be helpful.
And some of you are present
the rest of the world.
So you can be my test audience.
So,
oops, that's not the yes,
that's the one I want.
I want to start with John Kerry.
So this is kind of what we
have to, when we, you know,
motivated by Lucas took
or took earlier this morning,
we might think that, you
know, one of the key question
we have to address is
what is our response?
What is the responsibility
of the rich world reserve,
the poor part of the world
or rich citizen with a poor citizen?
And it doesn't start very well
because the climate unrave
the US is that, you know,
sets the stage in June by
testifying in front of Congress
that the US under no circumstances
will pay climate reparations.
So you would think that's not a very good,
you know, it's kind of a
pretty clear way to start
the negotiations for Kind
of the sharing of the boost,
the mitigation of climate
change moving forward
and the cost of the adaptation
that has already happening.
But I think it is very
important to just take
that as a given 'cause I
think it is true the US
will under no circumstance
pay reparations.
So I think it's just as a positive matter
at a normative level,
we of course you might disagree
at a positive level, I
think it's helpful to take
that under advisement and
say this is not happening.
But of course it's not just
about past responsibility.
So it's not just about reparations
because as Lucas told us,
the the mission responsible
for climate change are mainly
due to the current behavior
of rich citizens, most of which,
although not all of which
are in rich countries.
I plan to spend very little time
on this because I knew
that Luca was before me,
but I think one point that
was not, he didn't highlight
as much as it does in in most of his work
and which is really
essential to remind people,
although I do know it in this,
you know, the second line
after the US will pay reparation
and on no circumstances usually, well yes,
historically it was us, but
now look at China, they are in,
they are the ones, they are the problem.
So unless China fixes
their emission problem,
then you know, there is nothing we,
you know, it's going to be
limited what can be done.
You hear a lot of that in Europe,
which is kind of self-righteous feeling
that we're already kind
of ahead in the combat.
So yes, you know, but you know, had China
and then the US of course
and then India, they are
the one who are emitting
already a lot and more and more.
So frankly this is to them,
towards them that you have
to focus your attention.
But of course China
and India are producing a lot of goods
that are then consumed
in the rest of the world
and China and India are net CO2 exporters
and USA is a very big importer.
So is Europe.
So in other word,
when we thinking about using
this input output table
to think about the full carbon
footprint of a person we need
to take into account when
they drive the electric car,
they are the, the full
carbon footprint of someone
is whatever went to
produce said electric car.
You all know that this is so obvious
that Lucas didn't remind us
that this is how we are trying
to, that it needs to be computed.
But that's not the headline numbers
when we think about emission
that come to the news.
It's not the consumption emission,
let alone the wealth emission.
It's just the emission.
So I think the first thing
is to remind that it's a lot
of work obviously to do properly,
but as Luca emphasized, many
people have done it several,
not many, but several groups have done it.
And in particular he cited
Bruckner and himself.
The methodology are really different
to arrive at very similar results.
Both of them are a lot of
assumptions you might quibble
with all of the assumptions,
but the fact that they lead
to very similar result is encouraging.
Lucas was a bit more subtle
in describing his own results
than I will be,
but I like to remind
them by this 10/50 rule,
10% of the highest polluter
worldwide are responsible
for almost 50, for about 50%,
almost 50% of global emission.
And conversely, 50% of the
lowest polluters are responsible
for about 10% of global emission.
It didn't have to be that way.
In fact it's not exactly that way,
but it's easy to remember.
Since we have a Bruckner, the
Bruckner is the world bank.
The team found very similar results
and they have a nice map.
So I thought I would switch to them.
And then when you look at
where these people are located,
it is true that there
is rich people in who,
who emit a lot in India and
China in the Middle East also.
But it tends to be the case
that high polluters mainly
live in rich countries.
So this is the map of the carbon footprint
and of course the Sahel region of Africa
that we heard about this
morning is entirely blue
while the US is is bright red.
And with that notion of emission,
Europe is actually kind of orangeish
whether it would look better
if we didn't include consumption,
if we didn't include kind
of imputed emission from what we consume.
This is something Lucas has already said,
which is quite important.
I'll show you a little bit later that,
but again it was mentioned this morning,
and you will know that
there is a lot of kind
of emphasis on mitigation
effort in poor countries
and this idea that there would be a trade
off of between reducing
poverty and fighting
and avoiding making climate
change worse, but first order
because people in Africa
emit almost nothing,
even if their income were to double,
that would really not
make a big difference.
So this kind of a non-discussion to have
and for a non-discussion, it has a lot
of place in the public discussion.
So one summary of this first discussion.
So Lucas at even a smaller number,
but, so the way I read
this is that eradicating extreme poverty,
so making nobody lives under $2 a day,
would increase emissions by only 2%.
This probably represents,
you know, a tiny amount,
a tiny fraction of what richest
people in the world consume.
So we can kind of forget
that trade off in the sense
that first order, first of all,
poor people are extremely
poor and need to be less poor.
Now second of all, even if
we are only we're worrying
about climate, of course being poor
is a pretty bad deal to be
protected against climate.
The first order way of
adapting to climate change
is to have a bit more
money so that you can,
you don't have to work when it's very hot,
you can adapt your production
and so on and so forth.
So that is kind of a first
point I wanted to make.
The second point is again,
as Lucas already said,
the cost of climate change are going
to be felt in the poor part of the world.
He emphasized income
and I want to emphasize
mortality from the work by,
you know, people in this
home global impact lab.
But first, the first order point,
of course poor country are in
places that are already hot.
So this is temperature today.
And therefore, even though,
you know, suppose the earth
warmth by two degrees,
it's not going to be two
degrees absolutely everywhere.
But just to simplify,
imagine that's the case.
If you are in a place where
there are already many
very hot days,
then you're going to get
more of those hot days.
And then of course the
impact of temperature
on the human body's ability to thrive
and then to survive is not
linear in particular, you know,
above 30, 32 in particular,
if it's a little bit human on top of that,
is where it becomes just not
very congenial for human life.
And you are going to see
more of those hot days
in poor countries.
Already we see them more today.
I realized that I'm
keeping on your advisement
from this morning using the fact
that it's happening today already,
but you know, this is 2050,
soon enough we are going
to get more the hot days.
I should note this, the
North of Latin America
is also to be kind of gets
very red in these places.
And by, I think I skipped
one slide, by 2000,
it's even more hot days.
And you see a huge
concentration of the number
of very hot days in places
that are very poor in
particular Sub-Saharan Africa,
but also Pakistan
and the Northeast of Brazil for example.
The second point also from Tara Carlton
and others, this a big great group
of people at Chicago looking at
and kind of a lot of people they work
with all over have used
historical data to try
and compute the cost
again in term of human,
of human mortality of an extra hot days.
So what you can do is to say,
well it's been, you know,
in the past around the climate
there is variation from year to year.
Take a particular district in India
where there are more hot days,
do more people die compared
to a very similar district
where in this particular years
there are fewer hot days.
So that's, we can use this historical data
to give us an idea of
the impact of temperature
and mortality.
I should say this is really variation
around business as usual.
It doesn't include any of the
disaster that we're gonna get
to as well.
Flooding and this type, you
know, fire this type of stuff.
It's just temperature.
So this is very much lower bound,
but we are gonna stick
with that for the moment.
And so what they're
doing in their QJE paper
is to look at a bunch of micro regions,
they're fewer than that,
there's a bit of interpolation
involved in that.
And then separating
countries by cold countries,
hot countries, medium temperate countries
and then poor country, rich
country, medium countries.
And two things. First of all,
in places that are very cold,
when it gets hot suddenly
a lot of people die
'cause the places are not used to that.
So a few now,
almost a decade ago there was
a massive hit wave in France
and many, many people died
'cause we were so unprepared.
In the subsequent hit
wave we did much better
because we kind of knew
what to do with that
and visit the old people
and bring them to cinemas
or museum or so on.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing is that
in places which are poor,
mortality is much higher for hot days.
And this is because you don't
have you poor people tend
to work outside, poor people
do not have air conditioning.
So you take a very hot day in Texas
and people go from the
air conditioning home
into the air conditioning car,
into the air conditioning
office and they don't die.
But you're very, very hot day in Pakistan
and then people are working in a heat
and they have heat stroke and they die.
So when you combine all of that,
so this is what graph summarize,
when you combine all of that,
you get this maps, which
is the mortality effect
of a particular hot day.
You know, one more hot day, 35 degrees.
So of course in, you know,
in Greenland it would be very people,
if there were people in Greenland,
they would die when it's very hot.
But there are not going
to be very many hot days
in Greenland.
But then in Sub-Saharan
Africa where we already see
that there would be a lot of hot days,
then a lot of people will die
too because they are poor.
So when you combine the fact that, oops!
I'm not doing very well with
the slide, yes, that's the one,
one when you combine the two,
you the fact that there will
be more hot days in poor places
that are already poor and
these hot days will create
more death.
You get this map also
from that same QGE paper,
which is by 2100.
So maybe it's too find the
future for us to think,
'cause I think
we probably could do something
already like that today.
But it's very striking,
which is you have this big red blood blot
in basically Kelsey's field work,
the whole, the South region of Africa,
but also the North of South Asia.
And then most of the OECD's blue,
which means that climate change
will actually save
lives in rich countries.
So just so that you don't
get the message that you,
we have nothing to worry
about in rich countries,
this is just temperature
that there is all these other things,
there will be damage in those countries,
but from temperature alone, actually,
if you would just look
at the mortality impact
of temperature,
the impact will be
concentrated in poor countries.
So the estimate is that at in the business
as usual scenario, the RCP 8.5,
there would be 73 extra
deaths per 100,000 people
by 2100.
So, and of course in the
middle we'll walk through that.
Exclusively in poor countries
and that's more than all of the death
from infectious diseases today.
So it's like, you know, take
all of HIV, tuberculosis,
et cetera, that's going
to be more than that.
So this makes for, in a sense,
I'm just repeating in
different ways what Lucas said,
but this makes it for very
thorny political issues
because first starter
in the next many years,
the problems are going to
be felt in poor countries
at least the kind of first
problem of being alive.
But the principle margin
of actions are in the South
because this is where
people are in the North.
Sorry, because this is
where the highest emitters
are located.
So is it the case that
until now we've displayed
a great capacity to deal
with this kind of issue?
That's a bit of a rhetorical question
because we have the recent
experience of COVID,
which was a problem.
We've in a sense come from the North
and was exported to the South
where it came originally from China,
but it's not that there was
even that much COVID in Africa,
but we told them you have to
lock down your economy, right?
So this was this problem that
was at least a global problem.
And there were really two, two dimensions.
One where the kind of the world
could have globally acted.
One was financial transfers
and the other was vaccines.
On financial transfers,
there was almost no increase in bilateral
or multilateral fund flows
towards the poor countries.
So while the rich world
was doing whatever it takes
to get out of it.
So the countries in the rich world,
this is map from the IMF
about how much a country spend
in fiscal stimulus measures.
So the countries in the
rich world spend about 27%
of their GDP in fiscal stimulus measures.
The poorest country in the world spend 2%
And of course the GDP is much smaller.
So basically the smaller countries
weren't able to do much to
help their citizens adjust,
which led to this increase
in poverty in poor countries
which had no equivalent
in richer countries.
And it would really have
cost almost nothing.
It would've hardly registered
to borrow a little more
on top of the trillions.
We were borrowing anyways to
bring Togo at 27% of their GDP
because the GDP of Togo is
so small that this would,
you know, we would camera
hardly have seen the difference,
but this didn't happen at all.
So that's the first point.
The second case of course,
which was widely
publicized is the inability
to secure vaccine early in the pandemic
for the poor countries,
despite having an institution to do that,
which was COVAX, which
was set up to do that
and proceeded to be unable to buy doses
because the rich countries
had been holding them.
So when this was happening, I, my,
take on that was like,
oh wow, it's pretty bad.
First of all it's pretty bad.
And second of all, it really
sends a terrible signal
about the ability of the
world to share solutions
to problems.
And it's going to be very costly
for climate change moving forward.
And of course I didn't
know about Ukraine yet,
but I think we've seen the
direct consequences, for example,
in African countries refusal
to engage very much with what Europe
or the US had to say on Ukraine.
This at the moment seems to be a bit
of a stand standstill in
the, at least under pressure,
the world getting together to
share solutions and problems.
That's a,
so where are we after many, many COPS?
So that's a maybe an
unfair characterization
of where we are not enough
money going towards low
and million income countries,
the commitments are too weak
and they are not carried
out or they are not renewed.
There was a 100 billion pledged in COP
in Copenhagen many, many years ago,
which was never fulfilled.
I'll show you slides in a minute.
And to the extent that is spent,
that money was sent towards
developing countries.
It's mostly loans
and mostly mitigation,
which is nice enough,
but that's kind of nicer here, not there.
Vis-a-vis,
the cost that we are implying.
Then there was a COP27 reparation fund,
it came without financing,
then there was a bit
of a dead clock, maybe
it was dead on arrival.
It as it turns out,
not almost as timely as
the social cost of carbon
on November 6, a basic agreement
to have a fund hosted at the World Bank
as an interim trustee was reached.
But at the behest of the US
there is no obligation for anybody
to contribute to such fund.
So the agreement encouraged
but to does not oblige all country
to contribute to the fund.
So the developing countries are very up,
the low income countries are very upset
because the fund is in the World bank
and the rich, the US made sure
that nobody really had
to contribute to it.
So it's seems that there is a bit of work
to continue to work on that.
I'll stay at the, on on.
So this is what has
happened since the COP,
since the commitment in 2015.
So this is the amount of money,
sorry, the slides are in
French for some reason.
This is the,
what was sent, what was spent.
So less than a 100 billion,
but more importantly it is mostly loans
and it's mostly mitigation.
So basically we are lending
money to poor countries
to undertake investments that are going
to help reducing the carbon in
the atmosphere for everyone.
So it doesn't seem that
it's addressing the issue
of the cost that we are.
So I make a few points
before getting to the kind of proposal.
The first one is you cannot,
we cannot tackle climate
change collectively
without tackling redistribution
across countries.
That's post a kind of a
normative point of view
and also a positive position
because as you said,
currently the best way
to not die from hot weather,
hot weather is to be rich.
So no adaptation funds is
going to mean less mitigation.
In the absence of funds for adaptation,
what country want is
to become rich as fast
as possible and also to use
as much energy as possible.
If you look at the energy demand
that is estimated from now
between 2100, it's going
to be a huge increase in
energy demand for countries
that are hotter and have
the middle income countries
that have the ability to
purchase air conditioning
and to connect everyone to energy.
This is India, China, et cetera.
India is projected to
have an increase in 150%
almost in energy demand.
And they want to do that
like as quickly as possible.
So if it takes, if it
is charcoal, so be it.
So that kind of, there
is this clear dilemma
for emerging markets.
Say Ecuador wants money,
he would like to not drill the Amazon,
but if nobody give them money to do it,
they will drill the Amazon.
India wants energy
and therefore at the COP26,
the Glasgow at the very end,
they decided not to sign
the can side with China
to not sign the pledge to
wean themselves our charcoal.
And they say it's very nice,
but the problem is we have to,
we, you know, the real,
the thing that this summary
is like real climate
was climate injustice.
So that's the first point.
The second point is you
cannot tackle climate change
without tackling redistribution
within countries.
Again, that's a normative point.
The one that you at, it's
also a positive point
because when you try to
do something that is going
to address climate change,
they are going to be winners
and losers and unless the
losers are not pretty convinced
that they're going to make whole,
then it's just not gonna happen.
So in in France the,
we had this yellow jacket protest
where the people protested
with their yellow jacket and
what prompted it was an effort
to have a carbon tax on gasoline
and that carbon tax was
removed after about half a day.
But then the protest continued
but this is what launched it
and what it said on the jacket is,
"Money for fighting climate
change is to be found
in fiscal paradise,
not in the pocket of
the citoyen en colere."
So this, this, but this is very strong
and that's true both for carbon tax
but any regulation as well.
So people don't want to
abandon their old car
because they still need
to travel and so on.
In poor countries,
in poor countries it's
a bit the same thing.
So that's an example for, so in India,
Nick is studied intensively,
there is free power to farmers,
which is a problem for climate change.
It's even more immediate
problem for overuse of water.
But all the attempt to
remove the subsidies
or lower the subsidy
and replace them with say cash
has really have been really
struggled in the face of very,
very strong farmer opposition
and which here they call
it like midsummer madness.
So people basically do not trust
that this is something you can do.
So if we take into
account these two things,
this is where I come to the
more kind of going on the limb,
it seems that the world
needs to manage to commit
now to mechanism to
raise money for a fund,
which could be the loss in recovery fund,
which would be designed
to low income countries
and within that to low income
citizens, it needs to be fair
both nationally and internationally,
it needs to be permanent
because we have already showed
that we cannot renegotiate,
we have to have rules
otherwise it's not happening
and ideally provide some incentive
to reduce pollution along the way
because otherwise there is this,
the worst case scenario
would be one where people
in rich countries feel they're
now paying for their emission
and therefore they can
continue to emit peacefully
because there is no,
so how much should it,
so what I want to do in
my last few minutes is say
how much money is needed,
where we can find it
and how we would spend it.
So how much money is needed?
So the way, it's a bit of a
choose your own adventure here,
but this is the calculation I made.
Very simple. I'm taking
the Carlton at all estimate
of $37 of damage per ton
just from loss of life.
So this is not the total
social cost of carbon.
So this is just the cost that
transit from the, you know,
if more people die, we lose the,
all these statistical lives,
they have a number this
and therefore each turn cost
us in term of love of life $37.
Then you take the consumption emission,
not the actual, not the
production emission.
Consumption emission. If we,
if that change this number,
change that can change, add them up for US
and Europe multiply by 37 and
you get to about $500 billion.
So unfortunately this turns
out to be also the cost
that people say we need to
spend on energy transition.
So that creates confusion
'cause everybody wants
to raise $500 billion,
but it has not, it has
nothing to do with this.
This is not for transition,
this is what we owe today,
what we owe every year
to the poor countries
from the fact that we are killing them.
So that's about, so that's a lot of money.
Just for comparison, US total
foreigners is $56 billion.
So we are not in the same ballpark.
Now how will we find it?
So the number of these of
options have been discussed
including air passenger ticket levy, IMO,
transit, like ship levy
and so on.
My proposal,
so I want to talk about one
little proposal that I have
and also something that
Gabrielle Zucman's outfit,
the EU-Tax Observatory came up with.
The report came out 25 October
of this year, very recent.
So I just want to add that as well.
So in,
so my proposal is,
the reason why I propose
this is that I think
it would be feasible.
I think it's not crazy to
think that it could happen
because in, so this is a minimum
tax on large corporations.
So in October, 2021, a 137 countries
and jurisdiction agreed to implement
a major reform in the
international corporate tax system,
a global minimum tax of 15% of the profits
of the largest multinational companies.
So the way it works,
there are two pillars,
but pillar two is the
one that raise monies.
So for example, if a
German company pays 10%
of their profits in Singapore,
Germany will collect the extra 5%.
So everyone gets to, gets to 15.
So my proposal for this is to,
and just add to that,
and EU-Tax Observatory
helpfully allows you to,
to put your numbers, you know
how much you want to raise.
They have similar just for it.
So if the original plan was 25%
just to share that minimum,
then it through various
negotiation went back down to 15%.
Suppose we go back to 20.
So you add 5%, that's 400
billion euros right there.
Suppose you had 3%, that's
300 billion, billion euro.
If the US didn't want to do
that, which is plausible given
that they didn't end
ratifying the first one,
the Europe only could do it with two
and raised 200 billion
by adding, by adding 5%.
So the Europe EU could do a first,
a first then if we take the proposal
that came out in the EU-Tax Observatory,
which is not about climate,
it's about, you know,
just taxing people in general.
They are attack the, they propose,
they calculate the revenue
potential of an million tax
of 2% on the wealth of
billionaires in 2023.
It's 3,000 people in the world.
There's not very many.
2% wealth tax,
it's good to think about
it as a 40% income tax
on the interest that generated
because rich people have very
good return on the labor,
on the stock market.
So let's say they make about
5%, which is goods and tax
because most of it is kind
of reinvested and so on.
If you take about half
of the 5% that correspond
to about 2%.
So I think about 2% wealth tax, not as,
oh we have to tax the rich above
and below 2% wealth tax as well.
It's kind of aware of
bringing them to the type
of marginal tax rate that we pay.
So if you did that,
you could raise 258 billions per year
and today we are already
raising some money from them.
So it's an extra 200.
So combined 3% extra
on the corporation plus
this 2% tax rate.
And we are getting to five groups,
we're getting to 500 billion
relatively plausible.
Even if Russia didn't want to participate,
we still would get 200.
So, and there is a number of issues.
First of all the OECD thing is, you know,
it's still in the making.
The second big problem is
that in the original proposal,
the country that enforced the tax keep it.
So they have a strong incentive to do it.
Whereas here, I would
like to take this money,
and put it to that fund.
So the first problem
is, so is it feasible?
Well,
what I heard,
it could be done unilaterally by Europe
or really by any country
or group of country by adding
a tariff basically to the good
that come from countries
that are not taxing at the same level.
It's not great economists
do not like tariff,
but in some sense the IRA
in the US is also has a lot
of protectionist element.
So maybe, maybe the world
is moving in a direction
where politically at a
positive level it's feasible.
So we don't have to wait
for everybody to agree.
We can, for the EU for example,
could do the first step.
For the second issue that
it goes to our other people
and would people agree and so on.
So first of all, it's already the case
for whatever contribution
we send to the IMF
or to the or to the World Bank.
Second of all, there is very
interesting work by Adrian Fab
and then people, I don't
know their first name,
Douenne and Mattauch looking at,
they have a panel of 40,000 people
that interview on various issues
like regarding climate change
and they have tremendous amount of support
for a global wealth tax on
millionaire, the people to,
and then, so 67, in every
country it's 67% or more,
but on average it's more,
I'll show you in a moment.
And then when people,
so people are asked whether
they would be in favor
of a wealth tax on millionaire,
they are in general quite favorable
even though they don't
like taxes in general.
So this is,
and then when they're asked
whether some of this money
should go toward the poor
and in about people say that
about a third of that should go
to low income countries
and I should say it's a tax on
millionaire, not billionaire.
So you would think that
maybe a tax on billionaire
would be even more favorable.
Still from that paper,
you can look the support
for various proposal
that are global proposal
and you can see that where is
the one that I'm looking for?
There is a fair amount of support
for payment from high income
country to low income country
and next national,
the global tax on millionaire
funding low income country,
which is basically the one
I'm proposing as you know,
the US is the lowest support with 69%,
but then Europe is 84% support
and within Europe you see
this different countries.
So there is actually a fair
amount of popular support
for something like that, which
doesn't mean plenty of ideas
of popular support and
they don't happen anyway,
but at least it's not going
necessarily against the grain.
Oops.
Then the suppose that that
money is raised the next,
oh yeah, the third issue
is there is no connection
to climate change.
So this, I think we could improve that.
Right now I don't think
we have a great measure
of carbon footprint of farms,
but if we improve the
accounting of carbon footprint
of farm, now that we have the
right social cost of carbon,
we can kind of, that corporation,
this corporation tax could have
a carbon tax flavor to them.
And unlike the carbon tax are in general
and popular a carbon
tax, which is, you know,
basically maybe a rebate
for firms that are virtuous
from the minimum income
tax would work well.
So you could have incentive
build into the system.
Companies that improve their
carbon footprint could see
their liability reduced.
That would be perhaps acceptable.
Of course the fact touching,
taxing are very, very rich
'cause they consume more
and therefore emit more is in itself goes
in the right direction
from climate change,
from a carbon tax point of view.
Okay, so now that I have
my 500 billion, what do we,
what do we do with it?
How to spend it?
It's been a,
it's been a very, very difficult debate
and very angry debate in the loss in
for the loss in Damage Fund
that was proposed at the last COP.
It almost scattered, you know,
a few weeks ago there
was a political stalemate
about that thing.
Maybe they would not even
propose it at the next COP.
And the issue was very much
like where would it leave,
how would it work, et cetera.
So Thomas Piketty has a very short article
and then took in the, in a
book edited by Greater Sandberg
and talks also a bit in his
brief history of inequality
of something to, you know,
raise money from rich
countries, super countries.
And he that his proposal
is we should just give
it to the poor countries
and put it in the budget
and no question asked.
The issue when we combine with the fact
that actually there is
also a ton of inequality
in both emission, but also in the cost
of climate change within poor countries
is whether that would
go to the poor citizen.
So if we just put money
in the Indian Budget,
are we sure that it goes to
some of the poorest citizens
that are the most affected
by climate change?
So that's, so that one extreme.
At the other extreme,
and it seems that we are going
toward this other extreme.
The World Bank sets gets it
and administer it as a fund
with very little input
from the poor countries.
It has advantages because
they have capacity to do it.
And, but then what the poor
countries are really objecting
is that this money is theirs in the sense
and now it's administered by,
you know, in Washington DC.
So that's not proper
and there is a lot to say for that.
So, oops. So my proposal there again for,
and there, I think there
is a lot of work to do
and maybe I should have done this work
'cause maybe this is the place
where I know just I
would know a little more.
But this is where I've
done the list work is how,
so this is the three
things where I would spend
it if I had to think about it.
One of it is simply a automatic
transfers to household
that are triggered by climate events.
So today many more people
around the world are really connected
to within like a phone app away
or in India Bank accounts
are reachable by transfers.
So there could be rules that the, when,
you know, as a function of the situation
in the particular sub region,
everyone is entitled to that transfer.
They can even be ruler
is work by Stefan Dercon
and others looking at
anticipatory transfer
in Bangladesh paying people
before the event takes place,
which is really helps people, you know,
put themselves to safety.
Helps with adaptation.
So you don't comp compensate people,
you compensate people in advance.
It actually helps saving lives.
So there is a lot,
it's not true that everyone
is ready to be paid
for today,
today there is a lot of work,
just money to be spent to
create the infrastructure.
But it is feasible to
have basically pipelines
that touch a lot of people.
We now have so much evidence
that once people get money,
they use it well.
That this kind of transfer,
compensatory transfer when
things are going poorly,
if possible in advance
would be both be
compensation and adaptation.
So that's, you could probably
spend unfortunately quite
a bit of money on that.
'Cause there are a lot of these events.
The second is energy
access and leapfrogging.
So again, I don't think
mitigation should be shouldered
by poor countries, but on the other hand
there is really no reason
to build a charcoal plant
if you can do a, build a more expensive
but plant that is going to leapfrog,
create a good electricity grid and so on.
Do it with grants, not with loans.
And the third, and that's where
I'm preaching for my parish.
Going back to the debate,
to the one question that
was asked about the training
is there is so much we don't know,
we are just scratching the surface today
with a great session about
something that can be done.
But the research on
how household can adapt
to climate change,
how they can contribute to
mitigation at their own level
or even how to adequately
com is just in infant.
So I think that,
so there have been something
like development impact venture
at USAID or the Feed in France have been,
have shown great, great
success in reaching multitudes
of project all around the world,
really coming from the grassroots.
So for example, the Feed in
France, most of the project
that have been proposed have been proposed
from the grassroots in Africa in regions
that are very affected by climate change.
Let this project come
from everywhere, fund them
and learn from that what works
for adaptation, mitigation,
competition, et cetera.
Have independent panels
so that it's not like
the same bureaucracy of the World Bank
or whatever that is seen
as making decisions,
try to distribute these
panels around the world.
That could be kind of the third thing
you do with this money.
So let me conclude there.
I think there may be a
margin for action stay tuned.
It is also the case that
it's not that I have an ear
to anybody who can make that happen.
So part of my strategy
is to jump up and down
and hope that the message gets,
gets kind of relayed.
And I know that all of
you are part of this.
I think just putting this argument out
or that's my hope might lead
to even to other, you know,
not necessarily this,
but maybe other things to be adopted
because they kind of change a little bit.
The conversation between John
Kerry saying there is no way
we'll be operations to okay,
but what it is that we need to do.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(both murmuring)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry. So yeah, welcome
Lucas back to the panel here
and basically I have little to say,
I think we have, you know, 15
or 20 minutes of questions,
so I'd like to just engage
with the audience and see what you'd like
to ask about these great presentations.
Yeah, Ken,
- Great.
Thank you very much for the
very impressive presentations
and I appreciate the posing of a solution
after a very sobering
assessment of where we stand.
My question relates to the,
this is for Professor Duflo
on the 500 billion that you posed.
So that was coming from
the mortality costs
that are being imposed
upon developing countries,
but that 500 billion also depends
on the value of statistical life.
That's assumed.
And there are contentious
arguments all the time
about do we count someone
in Ghana the same way
as someone in the US
or much less depending on, you
know, scale it by their GDP.
So I'm wondering whether
that opens a can of worms
by tying it to the 500
billion to something
that is attached to a
value of statistical life
that may be very
contentious among the people
who would be receiving the funding.
Do you have thoughts on this?
- Yeah, great question. So there's that.
And then on the other hand you could say,
but we know why stop at mortality,
we should use the full
social cost of carbon
or at least the social cost of carbon
as it plays out in the poor countries.
And I think that's maybe
would be Tamara's view
or Michael s view,
but I,
I think it might be the
most helpful way to do this.
And that's kind of why I,
where I hope to go is to
choose your own adventure.
You know, this is the emissions
you can even go production, consumption.
The new,
the new
and improved consumption that
they're going to generate.
And then this is the cost.
This is, you know, $37 for
value of a statistical life
times the mortality damage
full social cost of carbon
and their value people
in low income country,
which I wouldn't personally do,
but you know, someone might want to do.
And that gives you a sense of where,
how this numbers might
play out for the one thing
that I hope to do is
kind of build this tool.
All of the data is already there to do it
and it would help people form their,
but at least they
would've to argue publicly
that that's what they choose.
And that would, that itself
would be interesting.
- Yes, Catherine,
- [Catherine] Fascinating
proposal. Thank you.
I guess I'm more optimistic
than you are about carbon pricing.
I think in particular the
EU CBAM is encouraging a lot
of countries, like just
yesterday Turkey announced
that they're adopting carbon pricing.
There are a bunch of countries,
Thailand, Vietnam, Senegal,
that are considering
carbon pricing in response
to the EU CBAM.
And there have been bills in the US
that tie carbon price
revenues to distributions
to low income countries.
And I could imagine that that would make
it more politically,
you know, saleable in
developing countries,
or sorry, richer countries
that people might be, you know,
I think first of all, like
communicating the fact
that carbon pricing raise revenue
and then using that revenue
for low income countries
could be something that makes
it more politically tenable
in rich countries.
- Yeah, I don't think that
carbon pricing cannot be done.
I think that they can,
but I'm not sure that if
you link carbon pricing
to sending the money in poor countries,
that would work out in
a country like in France
for example, that wouldn't play out.
It's like whatever.
Because people are so,
you know, the poor people,
they feel so much hardship
as it is even though their
hardship is not the same
as people in Niger that,
you know, they don't want,
they are not concerned
about future generation.
They're not particularly
concerned about people in Africa
either if they have to pay for it.
So, so I think urban pricing,
that's another discussion in
a way I think urban pricing
can work if you can credibly commit
that the incidence is not on the poor.
And I think it has been difficult,
but it has worked in
some cases, for example,
Indonesia successfully
removed a lot of subsidies
to it's not carbon pricing,
but it's equivalent when they tied
it to an unconditional cash transfer.
And I think there was enough trust
that it just went through.
Canada was able to do that as well in the,
at the same time when France tried
to do car imposes carbon tax,
like just before they had
removed the Wealth Tax.
So the optic of it was, it's
kind of a different discussion.
I think carbon pricing are feasible,
but they require a lot
of trust and pedagogy
and I'm not sure that linking
them to poor countries
would make it easier. But maybe.
- [Catherine] It just,
I mean you could read,
so what what's been proposed
in bills in Congress
is to like link some of it like,
you know, 25% or something.
- Maybe to jump in here.
So I fully agree with Esther
that national carbon taxes
would probably fail in so many
countries if they were tied,
if their revenues were tied
with increased spending
or donations to the rest of the world.
But in the CBAMs, so border adjustments,
there were proposals actually in the EU
that some of the revenues
of the border would be used
to compensate the losers
because in that case the losers
are outside basically, right?
But that battle so far was lost.
So the EU decided to keep
the funds for within.
But I think this is going
to be an ongoing debate
as basically the rates
or the implied rates
increase at the border
or the types of goods that are subject
to this mechanism get enlarged.
So I think the same principle
that applies within countries
that carbon pricing works
when the losers are well compensated,
CF British Columbia for instance,
I think it also applies pretty
well in the global stage.
So I think there's still
scope for these discussions
to be pursued in Europe
and in other regions
and countries as well.
- Yes.
- Thank you. Very
impressive presentations.
Thank you much indeed.
My name is Chaba,
I'm coming from the field
of diplomatic struggles.
You have indicated a couple of times,
a couple of questions that
may help us moving forward.
First,
I understand that we basically,
we are talking about a global system
of redistributing revenues and incomes.
On national scales,
we have the legal and
institution system for that.
We call it Taxation and Social Policies.
Do we have it on a global scale
and are we going to
introduce it at global scale?
The second,
you have mentioned that in the range
of 500, 3,500, $60 billion
might be raised, might be
needed to make a change,
which is about three times of the size
of the official ODA.
Can you tell me one single
country in the last 70 years
that came out of poverty due to ODA
and if the tripling size
would make a difference,
how that would make the difference?
And the third one,
I was very much interested in
where do you see the sources
of these funds that would
be globally redistributed?
And you never mentioned
the petrol countries,
just in the last one
and a half years, the Windfall profit
was much higher than
anything else in the last
1,000 years in the human
history, just Norway,
during one and a half year received
extra windfall profit without investment,
without an inspection investment.
That would be in real
terms, real prices today,
much higher than the whole
Marshall plan offered
by the US to the whole of Europe.
And that is now is out of our thinking.
Thank you.
- Yes, sure.
So we need a couple minutes left,
so I'm just going to
collect two, three questions
and then allow the panelists to respond.
Yeah, so cost us.
- Yeah, thanks for the present.
It was super illuminating,
the numbers for inequality in particular,
the numbers for inequality,
I find the numbers for getting out of,
you know, the carbon
cost of getting people,
getting out of poverty, kind of optimistic
because if we think of the
countries that, you know,
grew fast out poverty like
India, China, Vietnam,
they went through a growth
process that was much more messy
and the emissions increased massively,
also for general
equilibrium regions, right?
Like, you know, you have
to general create policies
that have many repercussions
of how you grow, how you emit.
But if this is a true
critique what I'm saying,
then this has implication
of how do you, you know,
what policies should you use?
'Cause redistribution
is not gonna be enough.
So I just wanted to hear
your thoughts about that.
- And I guess lastly,
yeah,
so Brian, you want,
- I had two rules.
One, I had one question on my own
and then there was one on
Zoom from actually a panelist
who was in the afternoon
and she sent it from India
where she stayed up late.
So I felt I should ask that.
I think my question,
which was a quick question
is that this poverty emissions trade off,
which I'm incredibly
sympathetic to politically
otherwise, my understanding
is it doesn't account
for changes in growth trajectories
of these poor countries.
And so you can imagine
that if Niger suddenly
starts growing at 20%
or something like that based
on fossil fuel development,
you may see very, you may
actually see a genuine trade off.
And I think that's the
thing that people are posing
is not so much that if you redistribute
and open them up, how
much they'll consume,
but rather if that country really changes
sort of this nature of growth.
So I'd love to hear about that.
And then this is from
Tarji who's in India.
She's one of the IPCC
authors in the afternoon,
for Lucas,
does the focus on income
distributions across the world
as though we have one
global community divided
into three classes, not
take away from the fact
that these trends are
still strongly mediated
by nation states.
How do we connect this inequality
across different levels
of development to nation states?
And then to Esther,
why only focus on the
eradication of basic minimum
or extreme poverty?
The study quoted is often used
to shut down arguments of climate justice.
- So maybe I could ask
Lucas to respond first
and then Esther to take the
several questions at once.
- Many thanks.
Maybe on the first point
on the carbon impact
of poverty eradication.
And so I think this is a valid point
and co-authors have a paper
on that basically saying that,
you know, after Bruckner
that actually it might be a
little more carbon intensive.
Although to me the real
challenge is what happens
after the, you know, $5.50 poverty line
and still the point that you know,
below 1.9 it's relatively
little carbon this point
is to me pretty, pretty strong.
The question really is what
happens, what trajectories,
what growth trajectories,
what consumption patterns
are associated with the type
of middle class
or non extreme poor life
we're talking about.
And so that's very much the issue here,
but not the eradication
of extreme poverty itself.
And I think, yeah, as Esther was saying,
we've been talking too much
about this, the second point,
national state versus
a global social state.
Well, I think first there
are some elements of that,
you know, very, very preliminary,
but the United Nations
operates does some form
of redistribution and so
that could also be one
of the recipients of the funds
that Esther was talking about.
The second answer I think is
really the due flow strategy
of trying to bypass existing mechanism
and create new ad hoc ones.
So if you add up a layer of tax
on the corporate minimum tax
that is currently being
negotiated, basically no one feels
that they're losing from it except
a few company shareholders.
But, so basically you're kind of taming
down the potential losers
from such measures,
but you're still generating new funds
and you can use them in different
either ad hoc mechanisms
in the UN, the World Bank or whatever.
But that's how I think
we can progressively move
beyond this national
versus international
social state discussion.
- Yeah, maybe kind of
without doing justice for,
to all comments, so on this,
I think your question cost
us very much this question,
which is, the thing is
China and India became rich.
A lot of people became rich.
It's not just the people below.
So when we would do this
calculation is really literally
what these people would consume,
but what happened in China
and India, they had a lot of very, very,
very rich people also.
And in fact some of the
highest polluter are in China,
India in term of conservation
where they have their billionaire
and they live in 50 floors houses
and they have cars and so on and so forth.
So, so that's kind of,
I think the distinction between the two.
So you were wondering whether
there is any precedent
for international revolution?
There is, we have the UN,
we have the IMF, we have the World Bank.
There is actually the
Bretton Wood Institution
are a mechanism for global redistribution.
Not very big, but nonetheless existing.
That's why I was saying it's not uncommon.
It's already in the system.
There is pipes for
sending money for France
to the World Bank and
that then that money goes
to poor countries in the form of idea.
So the principles are not unheard of
or maybe the the magnitudes
are are different
as you pointed out, you asked you,
you were asking if anybody has proven
that any country went out of
a poverty, poverty with ODA.
First of all, I don't
think one can easily prove
that one way or the other,
'cause it's not that we
have a good counterfactual.
Second of all, ODA is way
too small to take anybody,
any country out of poverty.
So even this idea would
be from richer countries,
we tend to think we are so important.
But in term of the budget
that goes toward poor people in the world,
there's this minuscule.
So it's not going to
take them out of poverty
if countries go out poverty,
it's because of what they do and if they,
or if something, if they
manage to fight the problems
that people face in poor countries.
So,
so I kind of think
that's sort of a non-question
in this particular issue.
And then going back, I think it's useful
to represent this idea, this money,
this 500 billion.
It's, I don't think it's one thing
that I'm pretty convinced there
shouldn't be a counterpart
that, oh, we give you this
money now you have to grow.
It's not something that we
would do out of the goodness
of our heart.
It's something that we owe,
whatever we can calculate how much we owe.
We can argue on the, we
can bargain on the on,
on the details, but it's not about,
"Oh, I'm going to help you,
but then you have to show
me you're a good student."
We owe that not so much to the
countries, but to the people.
And so the key difficulty
is to make sure it reaches the people,
whether or not the country
will grow as a result.
Frankly, I think it's besides the point
for this particular proposal.
- Wonderful. I think we'll stop there
and carry the conversation into lunch,
but a warm reception for our panelists.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
(gentle music)